now we're gonna sink or two you finished
my master class for drumming draft live
and pick it up right
welcome to scramble where I'm inviting
some of the biggest taste makers to my
kitchen to chat and make one of my
favorite dishes scrambled eggs and today
guess what we've got one of the biggest
DJs in the world right now now you may
have heard of these songs 365 in the
middle trust me I've seen him on a night
out in Vegas and he is brilliant please
welcome said hey nice to see brother
welcome to the madhouse thanks for
having me I'd like to think of this
kitchen like your deck okay you know
what you're doing
Yeah right I don't know what I'm doing
here I know I'm doing my progressed in
the overtalk thank you so much so we're
gonna start September October I believe
is the US and we're heading to Europe
plus UK and then we'll see maybe more
Congrats so we will do this together
okay go get their pants on why don't you
slick those ingredients to tell me okay
let's start with bacon yes let's do goat
cheese right goat cheese bacon shallots
and something green what fits the best I
think so if we render down the bacon
with the shallots
okay we'll finish the scrambled egg with
the ghost cheese okay by the way the
next time I see you I mean I'm gonna
come up and start touching buttons
perfect I'll teach you
okay and then we will finish the
scrambled eggs in fact let's do it in a
bun well scallions on there yes great
became let's do this together so there's
a there's a rule when we do slicing so
it's a three finger slice okay one in
front two behind I'll be the first one
here and we're just going nice and
slowly across hold that back together
then let the knife do the work there and
there were the butt of the knife a heavy
part let that
history so nicely fine like that now
watching you live is energetic it is
yeah and this whole new transformation
of that DGA
world now as you need because it's clean
its sophisticated and not only you DJ
but it's become a producing thing right
it is all about producing the producing
so when you got into music how old were
you I was about three years old or four
years old when I started thinking I made
great music and then I think when I was
four or five is when my parents start
recording me make music most persons
when you learn to play it was piano for
sure the piano fish I'm trying to answer
your questions when I'm so focused on a
three finger rule but yeah it was piano
I I studied piano classical piano for
eight years or so until I got so sick of
it that I want to do the opposite I want
to do something my parents didn't want
me to do which was play the drums in an
apartment where nobody could play drums
goes way too low no everybody complain
now shots time out bacon again we're
just gonna go a little bit sort of hold
it together this time and use the foot
of the knife okay and in terms of the
producing aspect now and no one quite
understands how technical that is yes
yes how do you how do you connect those
twos how'd you get that magic when for
instance the collaborations you've done
yeah you know they come to you with the
bass you add it do you need time when
your own there are you away are you
locked up what are you doing I used to
like to work on the road which I can't
do anymore I need time these days and I
need my chair
I need my comfortable space rut and I
need a lot of time to work with the
vocal said I record with somebody so I'm
gonna render that fat down I get that
nice and crispy that's gonna top this
okay and I think that's also a bit like
food when you think about the sort of 8
to 10 hours prep because it's a 1 be
receptive hours right to minutes yeah
people see the very end result they
don't really see the weeks and months of
work before that or in your case you
know the the day of preparation multiple
days what does that discipline
because like cooking there needs to be a
line that we can't cross and then a line
that we don't go under you want
perfection you want the latest yes I've
just never been different I've always
liked to be very good at everything I do
and that's just a like drive that comes
from within but even I want to be really
good at this at this dish I'm doing
right now I really want to not but I
just wanted to I liked being good at
things I'd like to learn them and I hate
imperfection when you were growing up
you went to the college Japanese out
there you know
absolutely not I didn't think I was ever
gonna be a DJ to be answered because I
was in a band back then and I thought
that I would be a professional drummer I
want to started making electronic music
I didn't even know what the hell I was
doing to be honest with everybody so get
that bacon out onto the and we'll get
that nice and drained now go crispy so
let's start off with the pan so you take
your pan over there yep no gasps is this
look
yeah that's low okay go off for now okay
because the secret behind the great
scrambled egg is not over stirring it
and so crack an egg on a flat surface
that way you don't get shell inside so
crack the egg here and open up and go I
mean you just did it like that yeah but
if we go slow so I just crack it just
bypass it and then see these pisidian
pop up over in there all right I have
not I have never done this I always use
a knife really and that two hands now
after that use both hands and do a
double tap you can do that last two eggs
really in straight one two three tap an
open that was pretty good I don't see
one okay one made it in there so we keep
the flame nice and low okay we'll take a
little bit of butter okay and just slice
one two little knobs of butter in there
so now we go in have your spatula yeah
we're still not put any heat in there
okay
and then we start staring as that's
going we're going to start stirring
you'll see the butter and that breaking
down how cool is it playing on me I mean
every time we go there it's queues
outside the door we know that's the
first time we opened up that I was I was
because I've always at another place for
three years before and this is you know
this became my second home but I'm I
love it now come off the heat now and
here's where it gets exciting we'll
still that around the outside here in
order to have an even distribution and
the exiting evenly uh-huh the plastic
scraper will go round there okay and
literally clean that down so what we're
doing is not allowing bits of the egg to
be cooking in front of the other part of
the egg and the butter stall melting
slowly so you go off for 30 seconds we
go back on for a minute again when you
see those collaborations you've done
over the last five six years how'd you
keep both parties happy how'd you find
that fine balance you just have to make
yourself happy ultimately some of my
biggest songs I was told by experts that
they wouldn't work because they're too
long because they have a job because
this because that sure it doesn't matter
you just do something that you love and
you're the artist and then people will
follow you I'm pretty sure I messed this
up anyway
in other words you're substantially
different at mine so it's I don't know
why yours is moving at such a fast rate
here's how to cool that down go in a
teaspoon of creme fraiche will keep off
the heat now and then mix that in there
here's the fascinating thing about you
also that a lot of people don't know if
you collaborate on the most amazing
tracks without the exposure anyone
successfully understands to be unselfish
where did that part of your career
become important for you you know when
you are a DJ or producer whatever you
want to call me I am NOT a good singer
right so I would be singing in front of
everybody right now I just penned on
people being incredible okay
so from the very start I can make
instrumental music all day long but I
realize that the love I have for vocals
lyrics and really connecting on a deeper
level yeah but it's almost like a chef
in a way that we are so relaxed have
been unselfish and nurturing talent and
seen them get to your level I think
music and food is about being at the
forefront of our industry and then
making sure we've got an infrastructure
behind us that helped us look good that
we make them look even better especially
in their own little world so
I mean I wouldn't be here if there
wasn't people believing in me what I did
for others well I was 100 the same don't
you yeah maybe you've got lots of
abdomen there right little seasoned okay
now's the time to seal it with salt
lemon pepper and you've got the salt
like like a rock salt and then from
there now
Bacon's done nice and crispy I can go
back on there without the heat on there
your slowly everybody slowly and then
for the final part the green bit mm-hmm
you take two and I'll take two thank you
okay so cut them in half okay and bring
the top half alongside the bottom so
nice and into one yep butt of the knife
again fingers finger take them out let
the knife do the work okay I'm not gonna
keep up with your speed no don't you
worry about the speed and then we lift
them in and we sprinkle that over the
scrambled eggs and then gently fold that
in there now for the exciting that this
is the presentation bit where chefs gets
so so excited so I'm going to spoon this
onto a bun okay okay so I'm gonna start
off with first just put a little bit of
the bacon bits underneath
that's the surprise there right bacon
and shallots underneath okay and then
from there and then start layering my
beautiful fluffy scrambled eggs on and
then spoon yours
it's fluffy its fluffy enough oh wait I
forgot to put the oh well Scotland's in
the first spoon always has to be without
scallions I read that somewhere it says
it's just better to for the first one to
be clean and don't you mix it in
otherwise you have too much of it I
learned that very early on it will touch
a seasoning on top cuz I just want to
face up there and then look I forgot the
ghost cheese that's the secret
ingredient look ghost cheese on top of
the bun there the scrambled egg is still
nice and warm right and that's the
surprise the ghost cheese on the bun
then show me yours I'll show you mine
that looks delicious
this is 100% the best scrambled egg
sandwich I've ever made because this is
also my first one ever and it's the best
one by default good actually looks good
I'm happy it looks very you raised the
bar right little taste thank you thank
you
young man you are on yeah I'm gonna
right stop the spoons let's go in I can
tell the difference in the texture well
I really can it's very very smooth I
like the ghost use again we do that
Thomas we just lift it up but you sent
me into orbit good job well I congrats
all the talking so much thanks for
having me again thanks so much for
watching and guess what you can find out
some small about says amazing orbit or
in the description down below and we've
got different Zed and we are remix in my
scrambled egg recipe swipe up to have a
great look now yeah it's great look